y'a le râteau et bruno nicolini bénabar
au carpont positive interprète de
chansons populaires et chouchou du
public pour le jeu de mots je m'excuse
alpha diallo dit blake n rappeur
français au sommet des hit garde le
sourire
il a conquis tous les purs bénabar et
black m compte parmi les têtes d'affiché
en ouverture du festival international
d'arc de château c'est la cerise sur le
râteau pour son quarantième anniversaire
la programmation la malaisie elle joue
les valeurs sûres
les jeunes pousses et la diversité
malgré la baisse 17000 euros de
subvention pour une enveloppe désormais
à 264 milles l'objectif est de faire
mieux avec moi savoir quand même qu'il y
a eu 180 festival qui ont disparu cette
année donc déjà être en vie et fêter les
40 ans c'est un exploit je parle souvent
d'éducation populaire de la danse et de
la musique et ce qui peut résumer au
mieux j'irai l'esprit de dark c'est
cette formule d'éducation populaire le
festival darc 40e édition
c'est toujours et encore de la danse de
la comédie et du chant plus de 600
stagiaires venus du monde entier se rend
présent 24 disciplines
obama pour un spectacle final qui va
réunir tous les stagiaires le vendredi
le thème métamorphose